should join vineyard forward
the kingsbury horn has inspired more
than a few farmers to action
show me what lies ahead
[Music]
what a handsome cat
hello friend of freyja what's wrong
hey dolly come back
no stop
oh
pig poop
you ran off again cats are free spirits
alouv and haughty
like the goddess freya i know but
ever since old cotter died that old sea
cat has run wild scaring the chickens
and scratching me
ah
ship's cats are good luck
do you need help catching him oh yes
please
[Music]
here little one
got you little mouse spider
wow
nally hasn't let anyone touch him since
old cutter died
but he sure loves you do you want to
join my crew nally you would make a fine
raider i think
every longship needs a brave cat for
luck and for the rats
looks like i have another raider
[Music]
oh
what we said
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
i know you are dead but hear me in your
soul
i do not think the horse can hear you
that horse can't hear anything so how
does he uh how did father do it then the
whole always comes when he summons it
father was a good horse someone i'll
have you know and i'll rise in his dead
[Music]
i know
easy
[Music]
your horse is a little unsettled but
safe
i
asked the great summoner first of a name
thank you next time summon a bridge
if father was still alive you'd be proud
of me wouldn't he skin folly
wait what did i call you earlier
maybe the horse will have a better life
now
you you little rat come back with my
horse
ugh
[Music]
oh
scum
no escape
i will got you
black eagles
skewers
feel stronger already
so
out of my sight
ugh
uh
hmm
ruins wretches spared you you're lucky
god be praised we were lambs before
their blades ready for slaughter you
draw breath still i heard the horns call
but i thought i was dreaming
i will join the feared just name the
place we gather at the ruins northeast
of northwich i'll be there
so
that horn came from elmham valdis must
have got to them the brothers fleet
gathered and ready
can we really do this we're just farmers
and merchants
have faith brother god protects the
righteous
i've heard the old abbott
finally
put my long shoes to use again
i was tired of it gathering dust our
ships are sturdy but ferg's walls are
sturdier
this plan of thinners is mad
men are pouring in from across east
anglia and our ships stand ready the
edwards reeve is with us his men will be
here soon more than his the kingsbury
horn has inspired men all across this
kingdom we will have the army we need
it seems also will got what he wanted in
the end saxon dane united in common
cause
a pity is not here to see it
the forces will be ready soon
are you ready to start the assault
i am
our target is border castle said to be
impenetrable
good
let them have their false confidence by
cover of night valdes will lead the fear
that the front gates with ruins men
distracted our forces move on the
seagate from the backwaters at their
backs and once we're in we'll leave no
gate closed in that castle ruits men
cannot be allowed to dig in further
your long ship is she ready
she awaits her own special glory
this land you call home is on the verge
of ruin
burned and pillaged by ruiz clan it
bears the scars of an age of endless war
but today we will reclaim her
today we fight for your land
and tomorrow we rebuilt for east anglia
for easter east anglia
now is the time today we read east
anglia of ruiz clan once and for all
oh
[Music]
you